let me explain something really
interesting when the most people buy
property when they feel when they feel
confident or when they feel scared and
they feel confident where are most
people confident about the market when
it's up or when it's down up so what
happens is most people and then the bug
in tune evolution this is what happens
properties go up and they go down and
they go up and they go down and they go
up and all I said this yesterday yes or
no right so most people buy when they're
confident and then when it dips they
sell so because of this and by the way
when property prices were really high it
was around about 2007 and then what
happened in 2008 crashed and then in
London what happened in 2011 shot back
up there's some parts of the UK where
houses today are cheaper than they were
in 2007 around 2005 2006 what did the
banks start doing 100% mortgages they
started giving out loads and loads and
loads of money what's the cause of
what's one of the causes for recessions
the banks weren't money that's what
happened in 2007 the banks were giving
out so much money they ran out of money
and they couldn't lend anymore and what
happened it was because they couldn't
lend anymore people suddenly couldn't
get mortgages and because they couldn't
get mortgages they couldn't buy
properties and because they couldn't buy
properties properties weren't able to
sell and the prices dropped and that's
why properties crashed however in 2011
they started giving out money again so
what happened is the prices went back up
but there's still parts of the of
England where they haven't picked up
yeah like Liverpool for instance
Liverpool is only just picking up now
and it's going crazy
Manchester only picked up three years
ago now it's going crazy but
Middlesbrough doesn't know yet
Middlesbrough still asleep
so that's what caused recession the the
other reason that causes a recession is
that the people were out of money so
sometimes when there's a lot of
unemployment or if everyone loses their
jobs or there's too much bad debt going
on and bother a bad day tinker
bothered by the system by the way bad
days encouraged by the system which
freaks me out
so they accuse me of encouraging death
Oh Samuel Lee's encourage people to go
in today I'm like too right I don't if
they understand the difference between
good day and bad debt but you system
encourage people to get into bad debt
and say no we don't yeah you do because
if I go to the bank and say can I have a
loan please for a house that I found at
the crash course they'll say it's too
risky but if I say can have a loan
please to go on holiday Oh to get
married they'll say approved that's just
the facts so why would it back happily
give you money to go on holiday but they
won't give you money to invest because
they want you to be poor because they
want you to go into debt so that you'd
be a slave to the system and continue
working in a job until you 67 and then
retire on 40% of what you couldn't
afford to live on in the first place
even after working for years 40 hours a
week that's the system you know so
that's that's the other reason for
recession the people can't go any money
the third reason for recession is
because of the fear of one of the above
and what happened in the last couple
years has been a lot of fear because of
brexit that's there's been fear but
right now there's places that are so
cheap like Middlesbrough where else
where where is cheaper now than it was
but like Paul correct where else
Bradford yeah correct where else Grimsby
correct Liverpool is correct he's going
up at the moment
hardly Paul correct partly Paul where
else
Durham there's a lot of places now this
is that why am I telling you this
how is this gonna benefit you in any way
I'm gonna explain something right now
which we again don't always say at the
crash course Susan but I just want you
guys to go and kick some ass I'm gonna
say it I want you to do it are you ready
yes or no are you sure yes or no all
right these places are cheaper today
than they were in 2007 and in 2006 the
banks were giving 100% mortgages so
right now there are people selling their
house for cheaper and they're in
negative equity now let me explain what
negative equity
means negative equity simply means that
the value of the house is less than the
outstanding mortgage if the value of the
house is a hundred grand and the
mortgage is 102 grams they cannot sell
the house they're in negative equity
they can't drop the price because if
they drop the price of the house then
they're not gonna have to pay off the
mortgage there what we could stuck now
when they are stuck what we do is we
offer a lease option agreement does this
make sense
yes or no before we offer a lease option
agreement we're not we're gonna offer to
do a below market value we're gonna
we're gonna this is really important
Steve bought a house for ninety five
thousand pounds his mortgage is eighty
one thousand pounds how much did he buy
the house for ninety five he did not buy
it for an investment property he's not
an investor he bought it for his son he
wanted his son to live in it because his
son was previously living in a horrible
grotty flat he bought the house in
blocks which he said to his son son pay
me for fifty a month which is the same
as she paid for the flat and live in
this house he wanted his son to be safe
Steve's mortgage payments were only 145
pound a month so was Steve making a
profit with that profit he was saving it
and his plan was thick when it got to a
significant amount to give it to his son
as an inheritance so he bought this boy
Steven nice guy is easy a good hide man
is he a good dad is he a good investor
correct don't kill you don't kill two
birds folks don't kill two birds if you
want to if he wanted to leave
inheritance he should have put the money
into a good investment and given his son
a better inheritance rather than trying
to mix it all up never works
he doesn't want to be an investor he's
not an investor what happened Steve's
son after six months moved out and moved
back to his horrible flat fingers up to
his dad
no interested is that it helped he's
ever tried and his dad's now got this
house lovely little house
paying 145 of the mortgages gotten a
tenant he bought the house in 2007 it's
now 2009 the house has dropped to value
Steve doesn't want it anymore Steve
wants to sell up
however when Steve goes back to the
agent they say that the house is only
worth around about 80 85 so now Steve is
in what negative equity now if I met
Steve which I did
Steve reached out to me what am I going
to offer Steve at least option correct
but as I said a moment ago I never offer
that first hope mainly so what am I
actually going to say to Steve let me
ask you another question
what would I often Steve or tell Steve
to do if he was my dad renting self
advise everyone as if they're your best
friend or your family
that's my rule so what am I gonna tell
Steve to do renting South I'm not gonna
make money from that good well from a
lease option agreement could that be
good for him yes but I'm going to advise
me of is if advisor my best friend part
of my core value system is to treat
everyone who's family so I said to Steve
Steve rinse out yourself now if Steve
went zi himself
I've not benefited anything but what
I've created is I've created some good
well my mission in life is to create as
much good well as possible because I
believe when you create good well when
you add value
Alberto stone says it best Elbasan says
this he says don't try and be successful
try and be valuable and when you
valuable the successful follow so from
my perspective if what often happens is
Steve rents out he's really happy and
then three weeks later he goes oh I've
got friend who's in a bit of a situation
and I said you with a guy I just want to
be the guy to god I get over 20 messages
a day from people saying I've got this
house I've got this piece of land I got
this why cuz I'm the guy I gotta fill of
500 people a week at my Center knows why
cuz I'm the guy cuz I add value there's
so many other guys and gals trying to
get the deal they're like hunters there
are no see Steve and they'll seem is
like a wild animal waiting to pounce
like hunter don't be a hunter in a
business be a father a farmer is so on
the frozen
and then just waits for them to start to
grow and then when they grow waters bump
and then when they're nice and big and
ripe and beautiful then takes them you
know that's how you gotta be in business
so I'm just throwing out seeds and
helping people and helping my students
I'm helping Steve this is 2009
Steve rent out yourself Steve says I
don't want to rent it
why not Steve because I've seen this BBC
show about slum landlords and now I
don't want to be a landlord I bought it
for my son all right Steve well why
don't you what am I gonna say now hello
market value I'm gonna do something
called this I'm going to exhaust the
options what's he called blaze thank you
why because if I offer Steve a lease
option agreement straight for it number
one is he's not gonna trust me because
you don't know me so I'm gonna exhaust
the options because I'm gonna build
rapport and build trust
number two is because the lease option
agreement works best for people that are
stuck so I'm gonna just get to the point
where we stuck you guys like scrappy rub
it out then just help now stay though
I'll buy off you for four sixty six and
a half thousand pounds
I'm exhausting the options I can't do
that I need to pay the mortgage but okay
I'm gathering information Steve keep it
on with the agent all right I'll do that
calls me back three weeks later still
not solved once I've exhaust the option
then and only then am I going to offer a
lease option agreement and when you
offer a lease option agreement here's
the rule never use the words lease
option or agreement because you can
understand how to what a lease option
agreement is you can understand how it
will help but unless you know how to
speak them what words to use you're not
going to get the deal sales shelter this
vulnerable person no trying to help but
helping equals sales gotta get that this
is helpful yes or no am i helping now do
we also sell sales equals helping you to
get that you don't borrow money right
now when the banks are lending loans
the more interest rates now 3% that is
lower than interest rates have been for
500 years if interest rates are as low
as they've been for 500 years and you
can fix them for 10 years but you don't
what are you going to tell your
grandkids I don't want that conversation
I'd rather have a come I don't want to
hear that for my brain kids why don't
you get off the sofa why don't you I
don't want to hit I want to leave my
example and I want to become wealthy and
inspire and give and grow and expand and
show my kids so Steve exhaust the
options they don't say why Steve listen
these are the words you want to use -
Steve these are the magic words I've
been doing this over a decade would you
like to hear the set of magic words
so Steve I may be able to offer
something like this that is the seven
words I usually all the time all right
so listen Steve so you've tried to sell
it at the age it's not work and you
don't want to mention out yourself and
you in a bit of a situation yes correct
okay well Steve I may be able to offer
something like this now at this point
what why those words so great why those
seven words so great because here's why
because I may be able to offer something
like this the psychology of is I may
also he's like I may I may not so if I
said to Steve Steve here's my proposal
straight away Steve here's my proposal
he's going to be like this Steve here is
my offer go ahead he's already in his
mind before I tell him what the offer is
decided that he's not interested because
people don't live in Seoul - here's my
offer
go ahead the person you sat down next to
yesterday within the first two seconds
decides if they liked you or not
and it'll taken two hours for them to
change their mind so now we're all
friends is that first impression Steve
here's my proposal ah go ahead Steve I
may be able to offer ya
what now he's leaning forward Steve I
may be able to offer something like this
was something like this so good people
might be able to offer you this Stephen
may be able to offer you this exact
proposal no because then it's not
negotiable
it's kind of like it's kind of like this
is exactly the now it's a bit more
negotiable it's open something like this
implies that you just kind of thinking
out loud now he's like yeah getting him
like that finding him stuck and then
getting him like yeah he's powerful
people can't do this and there's three
things you're going to say that's going
to be said in a sequence of
bump-bump-bump everyone do that with me
ready and Bom Bom Bom that's we need to
get the pan of this so this is the first
bomb Steve I can give you 95,000 pounds
for the property that's the first but
you can take a second pause we don't
pause too long you don't want him to
interrupt you just go go it Steve I may
be able to do swimming like this I can
buy the property off you for ninety five
thousand pounds but next bomb is this
but I wouldn't be able to give you that
for seven years
and now you need a reason because we
need to give the market chance to
recover that's the next Bob so Bob Bob
Seger's Steve maybe helps do something
like this that's your crescendo in I can
give you the ninety five thousand pounds
for the property but I'm not going to
give it you for seven years because we
need to give the market chance to
recover however this is your last bomb
right now I can take on the mortgage
take complete responsibility of the
property and become the landlord
ultimately giving you more money and
then you're going to end with a question
because if you don't end with a question
guess what he's going to ask you a
question and the person who asks the
questions is the person who's in control
so honestly you've got it you've got to
get really good at this asking questions
and any any if he asked you a question
you're gonna answer with the while
question god I learn to do this and
bother Jesus did
who are you who do you say I am alright
this is it this how you got a vibe
so Steve and what's your question in a
bit is it gonna be we're checking the
questions gonna be you got you got it
you got it
how does that sound you never say so
Steve do you want to do that are you in
Georgia sign the form right now the
reason that I didn't manage to raise
that finance when I was 19 is good let's
go remember form trying to get people to
sign it but it's really good deal and
this is what is the best deal in the
world where people have already decided
they don't like you don't know they're
interested switch off you can say I'll
give you a million pounds but if you
approach people in the wrong way they
won't they won't accept the money not
because they're stupid because you don't
have a cell Casals is everything Steve I
may be able to do something like this I
can give you ninety five thousand pounds
for the property but not for seven years
because we need to give the market
chance to recover however right now I
can take on the mortgage take over the
payments become the landlord ultimately
giving you more money
Steve how does that sound and at that
point what are you gonna do shut up
zip it it's gonna be a long ball good
silence while he thinks and you're gonna
be desperate to speak in the silence
because the finger Steve because Steve
I've done this before what no you should
zip it why is this so genius
bump-bump simple don't mention their
words lease option agreement cuz then
you'll confuse them and when you confuse
them you lism you're going to end up a
question it's a soft question it's a
precards succour Dupre close a close is
are you in how would you like to pay a
pre closes how does that sound and then
you'll just you'll determine what to say
next this bit is the only bit he won't
love because it's seven years he won't
love that however if he bought the house
off him right now what would he do with
the money pay off the mortgage how much
is he gonna have in his pocket he's paid
for his legal fees and stuff nothing so
what's the difference between giving him
nothing now and giving him what he wants
or give him ninety five thousand which
is going to leave
10,000 pounds in pocket but in seven
years but Ali alleviating the problem
for him right now it's a good deal but
still in his mind the seven years thing
isn't going to sit great which is why
you need a justification I may be able
to offer use to me like this Steve yeah
something like what I'll give you now
five thousand pounds but not for seven
years because we need to give the market
chance to recover however right now I'll
take all the property become the
landlord ultimately giving you more
money how does that sound
now this point there's going to be a
silence and then Steve well always say
why let me talk to the foot what I do is
you always have questions at this point
should say but Samuel I've never heard
that before
is it illegal Samuel I'm in seven years
why seven years and and then some what
about the mortgage who will pay the
mortgage will you pay direct to what I
pay what about the insurance you'll pay
the insurance there's 162 questions
Steve could ask here's the great thing
when I was 19 and Steve was asking me
all these questions
this was the third house I bought
believe everything is littlewolf but
Steve's questions guess what I'd never
seen a lease option agreement I didn't
know the answers I don't know the
answers so I'm like hmm boys questions
so it's hit the Steve I'm like I'm not
thinking only time I need a day to think
about this so I hit the Steve ah Steve
um what why don't you just sleep on the
concept give me time to think
um and also Steve right Steve why don't
you speak to a solicitor about this
because he'll know all the legal stuff
and Steve wait all right yeah I'll do
that
I said I'll send you an email with with
the outline and also wants this to
details and you can just do think about
it I leave it on what oh man I should
have closed him closed two days later I
get a phone call from Steve he says
Samuel except on the concept it sounded
good but I had a lot of legal questions
about how it works
I've spoken to the solicitor and he said
that this is how it works bomb bomb is
Steve talking I'm thinking my goodness
you knows more about these options than
I do I'm not okay I call call
he says Samuel I am ready to go I'm like
wow now here's the crazy thing
I did but I didn't attend those that I
got the keys took over the mortgage
payments of one four five moved the new
tenant in paying five fifty made for was
making Foreman dependent of gross profit
on that property seven years later I
bought the house I bought the house for
ninety five thousand pounds but the
value of the house was one five two so I
made about sixty about 60 grand in
equity four hundred pounds a month in
gross profit for seven years which is
thirty thousand pounds looking like 80
grand crazy money on this one house I
didn't know anything about these options
here's the crazy thing
Steve was happy it was good and I
realized that my solicitor did all the
selling for me so guess what they're
after I started just saying that spot on
my script
here's Mike and iam principal
bum-bum-bum what do you think has it
sound so interesting but I got these
questions do sleep on it speechless
Lister his his details give me a call
back if you interested it means I don't
have to go into it it means that I don't
have to be anything less listed a little
selling is this Lister a third-party
parable person yeah of course
now listen some people some of my
students I want to know everything about
these shorts I'm like I don't know that
when I started out in fact when I was
starting to know it and I got really
good what happened is the sellers would
say to me what about all these questions
you know and I'd say I'm start answering
them and it would turn to like almost
like a confrontation what happens about
the mortgage then what happens about
this oh all it happens is blah blah blah
it's really simple well that if you die
there for me do I look at me on physical
physique I'm gonna die okay hey it's if
you start arguing with the guy and
answering these questions because you're
the person that benefit financially it
becomes like a bit of a what you're just
saying speak to a solicitor third PI he
speaks the system but thus mister wants
the fee the legal fee so the system
wants it to go ahead so he sells that
it's legal it's right
good system board shock a ballad boom
follow the script how do you think you
could do that Red John said I
[Music]